yo it's the bootleg cat podcast man
episode uh
[ __ ] i don't even know what number we're
on right now it's a lot going on
with that being said we got my bro bro
chevy woods you already know
taylor gang is in the building the show
all the time bro
um welcome man you know we did like a
little zoom
interview it was even before your album
came out
what was it like in the middle of the
quarantine which we're still in the
middle of yeah
it was in the middle it was it was
before the album no it was before
before the album yeah no it was before
the album came out well since birth is
out
um how has life been for you man since
uh
all the [ __ ] has been kind of like
collapsing around us in los
angeles because i know you've been out
here pretty much the whole time yeah i
mean i never thought that it would be
like this
you know what i mean like uh especially
dropping music and [ __ ]
putting the album out in the pandemic
[ __ ] like this not being able to move
around
yeah like tour yeah like even even like
this you know what i'm saying like
at least it opened up a little bit for
us to be able to do something like that
honestly that's why you know we've been
talking about me doing this podcast for
so long and like
they shut the radio station down so we
can have guests there
probably till next year and i'm like yo
this zoom [ __ ] this instagram live [ __ ]
is
like kind of whack yeah i mean it's not
no to
me honestly there's not no feel there
yeah and it's like
everybody like you know what like i mean
and and it's it's it's good for artists
because you know like these radio promo
runs
are draining if you're a rapper right
and you got to go and bounce around all
these corny ass radio djs in every
[ __ ] market it can be a lot
now you can just be like all right let's
do a zoom yeah
i mean but for somebody like me i feel
like putting out my first
album after all this time i feel like i
want to i would want to no you want to
go
you want to do that it probably wouldn't
it's crazy to think that this is your
first album
yeah super crazy and and i always tell
people this is 17
projects before that's what i'm saying
like what makes this the album and what
what what about all the mixtapes
i mean like this is your first album
it's so wild to say that out loud like
yeah it throws people off too you know
what i mean because it's like
they put they pull up projects and be
like this wasn't the album
i'm like no i didn't say that it was
like it was a mixtape you know i mean
like
i didn't go i didn't go like pause as
hard as
as i like on a mixtape i can go in there
and do that [ __ ] in a day or two if i
really want to
you know i mean like the whole project
right and then put it out in a week
but with the album i feel like i had the
album six times before
and so this is like the sixth rendition
of your first album yeah and then i just
i've been trashing it the whole time
like nah i didn't read it ain't ready
ain't ready
yeah what's like obviously you know
everybody knows you from being taylor
gang and
and um you're kind of like wiz's right
hand man
i think like you know if if you see whiz
you you know you see chevy
like it's it's you guys are you know we
talked about this on ig live you're like
the scottie to his jordan and like
um what is like
do you feel like there's like a lot of
pressure like being like
this is your first album i know that
like
a lot of people have been waiting for
your [ __ ] for a long time bro and like
it's almost like we haven't i mean
you dropped last year right didn't you
drop a mixtape last year was that 2018.
you know i dropped a project last year
too yeah you're like it's crazy though
like
do you feel any sort of pressure like
being as like
we've been seeing you and and you've
been putting out so much content but
this is like i feel like that debut
album energy is so different than
everything else
that anybody could ever do because it's
like you think of nas and nomadic and
doggy styling mm-hmm and that's where my
mind was that anyway like of course
it's the baby picture you know i'm
saying so i thought you know in my mind
thinking of like classic
music and how i used to listen to albums
from start to finish without skipping
that was my whole thing like i'm gonna
do the when it's time i'm gonna do the
baby picture because that's like my
classic
album oh my gosh yeah it's like the the
nose
ready to die cover the wheezy cover you
know what i mean so like
all of those were like inspiration to me
having it but i don't and
and i don't what y'all need a little
wayne was the carter three was a little
waiting
quarter three i think so yeah quarter
three nah and the pressure thing is
i've been out the door for me you know i
mean like i ain't gotta
i don't gotta live up to nobody's
expectations or nothing like that
anymore i feel like years ago i probably
had to right because
wiz was at so high of a point that
people were looking like
oh his man what is he going to do next
blah blah blah blah blah
but i never lived in that world you know
i mean i just basically just did my own
[ __ ] and he supported the same way
right right regardless um how do you
feel like
because obviously taylor gang is has had
so many different
incarnations throughout the years there
was like that
double xl cover where it was the lola
chick
and shout out to lola juicy and thai
juicy ty yep um
and then it seems like even cardo was on
that cover
cardo shout out to cardo for being so
instrumental in
the sound early on man but then like
more recently you know there's like
you know the guy uh
skate there's you know these younger
artists
what's dude's name um daisy no i'm
thinking of uh
dude from [ __ ] houston is he from
houston oh social media social media
yeah yeah yeah for sure
yeah like there's like you know like i
just feel like there's been so many
different but you've kind of always been
the constant besides obviously wiz
khalifa
um do you remember like the early days
of like when you all decided to call the
[ __ ] taylor gang
like like what were like those early
days like you were probably not even
chevy woods yet you were probably kev
i was yeah definitely kev the hustler
kept the hustler yeah it was it was
basically off of like
we didn't i didn't weird chuck taylors
and [ __ ] right what i'm saying like i
didn't really see those come about
into like outfits until i met wiz
you know i'm saying he was wearing them
with everything you know i'm saying and
i'm like what the hell made this dude
wear these shoes
bro like these are like some of the
wackest shoes ever
and i'm saying especially to go with an
outfit and like be in the streets
because he was in the hood with us like
right now i'm saying constantly like
every day
and people would be like yo what's up
with your man bro like what
what what he got on and uh but i just
kind of like
took the time to like figure out why he
moves and why he does the way he why he
thinks this way you know what i'm saying
so
i think that it definitely comes from
the shoe and then
it was just his own thing and then we
came around you know what i'm saying and
then with like 10 of us
from like from like my neighborhood
right right and boom
taylor gang now i guess now he has
something to call it a actual gang of
people you know what i'm saying so it
came from the shoot and it came from the
people
yeah the entire chuck taylor and
and camouflage cargo short thing was
like
uniform yeah it was uniform for me for
like probably longer than it
should have been [ __ ] cargo [ __ ]
right bro let me tell you something
there's something like fire about like
somebody making like a 34 dollar shoe
cool for like poor [ __ ]
yeah i could go get me some [ __ ]
chucks and be lit for the show
for sure use we used to i mean we had it
was a point where
we used to just wear everybody on tour
like when we were on tour
like you said that was the it was the uh
the shark hoodie the utv
and then it was like you know either a
crew necked that way or
the camo shorts with the pulled up socks
with the chucks
or they were other you got i remember
when wiz had like a real flash cloud
kicker hoodie that he put out that was
that i caught shout out to cloud kicker
yeah
wow cloud kicker that was like that was
like the beginning of like getting
close from people [ __ ] yeah that shit's
crazy like yo we got a box for you i'm
like huh
what's that mean yeah free clothes free
clothes that shit's crazy
um what do you miss cause you guys were
you guys usually every summer you guys
do your tour
right like was it kind of was it dope to
have have this year off
you know get a break or you missing the
road yeah i'm missing the road for sure
because the thing about it is the year
before we got
back to it we took off and that was
that's right
that was a break between like six seven
years of time yeah
so when we got back and then now it's
cut off again you know like we itching
to like be out there yeah i feel like
it's almost like one of those things
every summer where you're just like all
right who's whizz bringing out on the
road this year mm-hmm
for sure i missed that too like you know
just a camaraderie of people and
hearing what names are going to be out
there and knowing who you cool with and
knowing who you want to get to know
and stuff like that hey do you remember
the time that wiz
did a show in flagstaff at nau
and his cousin played football there and
then we all went and took over like a
frat house
in the in the mountains was that here
i don't know if you were there you would
have remembered if you were there never
mind you might not have been there but i
feel like you're at every [ __ ] show
i know because the only only one that i
really remember
is like in in arizona i mean of course
they
used to had a spot called red something
or something oh yeah club red club red
damn that was early huh yeah like even
that and i went back there with uh
kevin gates in like 2015. yeah i think
the last time i saw you solo was uh
in scottsdale you and bernard did a show
yeah
shout out to the burn man um yeah i just
feel like the road man is like
some like i feel like you guys i have
done it for so long in the summertime
it's like [ __ ] it's crazy to think this
is the first summer it's
my life where there's no big toys yeah
it's crazy
let me ask you a question what do you
think about when the get back happens
next year
how many people's gonna be trying to go
out some people ain't gonna get their
chance i think that
there's gonna be a uh adjusted bag for
the times
for all the artists right like you might
have to take like
15 grand less than you're used to taking
or like depending on you know what i'm
saying just because
because you have to kind of factor that
in not only that right
but the costs if you think about if
you're a promoter
and you want to throw a show the
precautions are way different now yeah
you gotta like
make sure everyone's like [ __ ] you
know maybe sprayed down before they walk
in
like that i don't know like bro i went
to uh i went to mexico
last month and before we could go into
the resort
you got to stand under this thing and
then miss you with [ __ ] sanitizer bro
oh yeah see this [ __ ] was wild shit's
getting trippy
but yeah the shows are going to be
interesting because
i think once there's a uh [ __ ]
you know uh what am i
the [ __ ] that they give you
vaccine a [ __ ] vaccine the vaccine
the [ __ ] that they give you yeah aka
that might be some [ __ ] that they give
you though too like people
they don't know man history is crazy
like there used to be vaccines and [ __ ]
like that back in the day where they
give you [ __ ] they give you the [ __ ]
that
they purposely gave yeah so they could
spread it so are you gonna go take the
vaccine i'm gonna wait at least
unknowingly i'm gonna i'm gonna oh i'm
gonna take that [ __ ] eventually
i should hey look i don't i haven't dug
in enough to the uh
anti-vaccine [ __ ] conspiracy hole on
the internet but i gotta check it out
it's a place i'm willing to check out
yeah me neither but i feel like it's 50
50.
i don't know i mean it's documented that
they purposely
uh injected black people with syphilis
see what i'm saying
that's like official that's official
just think about the last person you
heard have chickenpox
i haven't had chickenpox in a long time
but as a kid you haven't had it once
back then it don't come around no more
do you think that's because
people got vaccinated i mean isn't that
good
i feel like it was something that was
put here just like everything else oh
almost like it was some man-made [ __ ]
yeah bird flu where's it at
anthrax where's it at it's like that
[ __ ] just don't up and leave
listen man the corona i already had the
coronavirus like
four months ago so i'm i'm you know that
[ __ ] sucked
maybe i'm already [ __ ] immune what
was that like well this
i just couldn't honestly for me it was
like
i'm a [ __ ] idiot and scottsdale
opened back up
so i went out there and dj'd like a
[ __ ] idiot
and then swaley i dj'd his mansion party
in scottsdale and then like
three days later i had a sniffle and i
was like yeah
you know it's a [ __ ] sniffle whatever
i got back to la and then i i couldn't
smell and i was like [ __ ] i got this
[ __ ] yeah
so i just couldn't smell and then i was
like fatigued a little bit
and basically that's the first thing
that goes it's like you smell
yeah i'm just glad my taste didn't go
away because i'm a fat [ __ ] so i was
you know i like to enjoy my food it
definitely was affected
but yeah i think shows are going to be
extremely um
different for at least in all the next
year this way
if drake goes out if the baby goes out
if wiz goes out
if travis scott goes out if
some so-and-so goes out that person
in that household cannot buy all those
guys well i feel like that was already
happening
there was some summer it might have been
last summer
or the summer before there was there was
like [ __ ] 15 tours going on
and like one of these is taking the hell
yeah somebody got it lose because they
know like you said no no
nobody who's normal can afford five
arena tour
[ __ ] tickets that's 50 bucks a pop
like you know
i mean and you got to take in
consideration you saying to yourself
these are my favorite artists i'm not
going on the lawn
i'm buying them yeah you got to go with
abroad or you got to go with your people
and then you gotta get a babysitter
outfits
[ __ ] you know what i have shows yeah i
don't know man i think i think the
concert is gonna be [ __ ] up for a
while
i think it's gonna go heavy in the
digital space for a little bit
like i know some people who are some
heavy hitters that are like putting
together some like digital
like pay for concert [ __ ] which i think
is kind of
honestly [ __ ] whack but me to like
watch it
like you just watch yeah like people are
performing like i think that shit's
terrible
yeah i think i think i mean if you can
get a bag of course you're going to do
it if you're an artist but it's like
that kind of takes away the whole
purpose of the road
the road is to like build up more fans
see the people with your own eyes
you know interact with your with your
especially
if you're doing smaller venues that's
like the most important like stage of
your career when you're doing like
500 person venues and you can go and
like see
like your and then you give them a good
experience and then they go tell all of
their friends times 500 and then the
next time you come back
it's like a thousand person videos 500
to a thousand i feel like everybody
has [ __ ] staged uh dive in the crowd
you have to like
the thing is it's crazy because there's
some artists who are
shoot so fast now where they're just so
big so quick that like
they don't they need some of these
[ __ ] never got the opportunity
to do
that those kind of venues they get
thrown on some major tour first
that's a fact it's like yo that like
that solo little run even if you
do 200 tickets a night like that [ __ ]
matters
that's just how you spread your fan base
like i don't know though man we'll see
what happens
i know whiz just did like a [ __ ]
uh he performed in the backyard yeah
like the virtual
for [ __ ] genius yeah yeah yeah that
[ __ ] was
again i think that's where shit's going
and if you're an artist i could do the
show in my backyard yeah that's
i mean you for sure are gonna be like
yeah i thought the only thing i thought
was cool about that is like
fans could vote on what song he
performed next that [ __ ] was fire
can you imagine if they figure out a way
to do that [ __ ] out of like a real
venue like on an app well and like the
like you're performing but the fans are
in the crowd voting on what you're
that shouldn't be hard as [ __ ] because
it's cool too for the artist like you
want
you wouldn't like you already have your
catalog you know what's up
if the fan is hitting the song on the
app
and the and it comes through like the
in-air [ __ ] you know what's coming next
so you ain't
gonna [ __ ] up you know saying so it does
i mean i know you know with the
like people having their sets and [ __ ]
it could be a little interesting but
yeah i don't know man
um talk about what your album like i
know you you kind of switched up a
little bit of
the sound on some records especially
like with the melodic [ __ ] i mean
going in in that direction on some of
the songs like
and you've always kind of done that to
an extent but like what is
do you feel like this is like your
i feel like i've heard the growth on
this project
the most that's where that's where i was
at with it in my mind
too i so 2019 like we talked about i put
out one project
and with that one project we were on
tour as well
when i got off tour i was like you know
what i'm i'm not even going to hurry up
and rush to be like yo i wouldn't need
to put the album album album
i just got my pen right you know what i
mean so i got a bunch of song like maybe
100 200 songs from 2019
that i never even released just because
it was like me it was like studying
practicing and [ __ ] like that so i like
put that on myself and said i'm not even
going to worry about the album just
going right
right right right right right and that's
why you hear the melodic sounds the more
uh
there's more message in it you know what
i mean like a mixtape i can get in there
and blah blah blah whatever i want to do
but
this is like personal [ __ ] that i
haven't said in all this time like i
haven't
said stuff about like my uncles and like
things like that passing away and like
not being at home when my grandma passed
away and not me being at the funeral and
things like that
being in the hood [ __ ] turning their
back on you [ __ ] kicking in my door
and come to find out it was some [ __ ]
i knew and like you know i mean stuff
like that so i never really talked about
like my
one thing i really didn't talk about is
like my car getting shot up 12 times
with me
in the car and not getting hit you know
what i'm saying like back home
yeah this was back home right in front
of my mom's house you know when did that
happen what year like
maybe i want to say
16 like 2016. that just happened 19.
yeah so it was trippy
it was it was like not trippy but it was
it was trippy like tripp
i was about to say trippy red was like
12 at this it was tripping me out
because it's like it's on the block
it's on the block where i did everything
you feel me like
in front of my mom's house so when the
[ __ ] started happening i ain't even
really like
it really were you inside of your car
yeah bro i was sitting there like
rolling weed like smoking like rolling
weed about the smoke
and i had talking to some girl on the
phone and i like hey
when i pulled up i never put my because
what i do is when i pull up if i'm
listening to music
i let the song just play right and then
i turn the car off and get out and go
no matter what i'm listening right but i
was just rolling the weed and like
talking to some girl and
all i heard was wow and i ain't paying
no attention because it's
my block i'm like [ __ ] shoot in
the air and do [ __ ] all the time right
it was 9 45 in the morning though
wow i'm like whoa whoa
i'm like oh [ __ ] they shooting at the
car
mind you i'm still looking straight not
knowing where it come from
and then the fourth shot i looked over
and i hit the car too like wow
i'm like oh [ __ ] then all the rest of
them start coming to the windshield
i slid down hit the door now my foot's
on the brake i never put the car in park
i slid down hit the door latch let my
foot go off the brake and the car went
that way like towards where
the [ __ ] were shooting from and
then i just ducked behind it
and let it roll and then like skirt
around the corner and [ __ ] and it was
like
and at that time i never like as i'm
running like there's a little corner
store it ain't funny but it's funny
there's a little corner store
my adrenaline was going so crazy that i
even know if i was hit or not
but i could feel the [ __ ]
whizzing past and hitting the
head rest i could feel all of that [ __ ]
like you did you were like [ __ ]
yeah so i just so you sit down like you
opened the door and just kind of rolled
out of the car and bounced yeah like i
put my hand down and like
kind of like creeped up the side of the
car and then like two more shots went
off like pow pow and i'm like all right
cool let's get around the corner were
you like
do you know who it was you know the
streets you know
well like at the because i feel like i
mean at that time did you have any
sort of issues with with some nah that's
not even like my i feel like that's not
your energy yeah that's not my energy at
all but you know i
you know where i'm from and you know
family and you know stuff like that i'm
in
you know i'm saying i'm tied in
regardless of anything you know i'm
saying
and you're part of it you're probably
like the face of the fam because you're
the biggest [ __ ]
yeah that too but you know it's like
it's just it's you know neighborhood
[ __ ] man
neighborhood [ __ ] sometimes you don't
have nothing to do with [ __ ] and that
could have been like a
you know a bad case right there for for
nothing type of deal
you know what i mean damn i didn't know
that man so yeah because i never said it
i never i never
you know what i'm saying like you see
dolphy like put me a mixtape called 100
shots like
at the same time i was like yo by the
way shout out to young dolph
not only for being the good homie but
jesus man they really try to get that
food he pulled through
twice like these [ __ ] was
really trying to kill the young dog for
like a year
straight yeah that was crazy and that's
all i could think of at that time i was
just like [ __ ]
and like now with the nipsy stuff and
all that [ __ ]
i mean what was the young man from
pittsburgh who died the same day wapo
yeah yeah yeah yeah man that's crazy
because you could have been bro
like i think that that is the one thing
like when x when x got murdered
it was like yo man like you cannot move
around
where you're from like it's all good if
you're his if you're that big
like it's it sucks to say it but it
feels like
where you're like instead of people
being the most proud of you where you're
from
it's like you get the most hate if you
may if you're and it's crazy because
you're the most that's where you're the
most comfortable as well yeah you feel
like you
you know it's just i feel like people
really
you're you're like them and they're mad
that like well what's so special about
that guy
like he's from where i'm from like and
i'm [ __ ] still you know
i don't know seven kids in the trap
[ __ ] it don't really be people in
your it only
it's not people in your circle or people
that you know or like people sometimes
in
a few cases it's people you grow up with
right but it's just some random
losers yeah it's like from the from the
city it's like it'll be a lot of talk
i'm not even [ __ ] famous like that
but i'm from phoenix and there's people
who want it like
like i don't even know these people and
i'm like wait you why do you hate me
yeah they don't like you because you're
positioned i'm so confused
yeah yeah it's ridiculous damn well i'm
glad that you man
that's crazy that's crazy so you're
when when did your grandma pass away uh
2014.
were you uh were you on the road 2013
matter of fact
yeah i was on the road i was in new york
matter of fact and like um
i got a message from one of my cousins
and they were like
call home like call your mom type a deal
that's never good and i'm like calling
my mom and it's my mom's
mother right so like when i called and
she was telling me about it i was like
what it's crazy because i at the time my
my grandma was like getting she was
older you know what i mean
but i would go up there weekly when i
was like home and [ __ ] before i moved
out here
i would go up there weekly and just take
care of [ __ ] same with my granddad that
pass
like take care of [ __ ] you know because
they was always there
right and showed me [ __ ] i always stayed
at night and watched wrestling at my
grandma my granddad was always at
uh [ __ ] sports games and [ __ ] like
that all the time so
yeah i was in new york man and like it
was at a time where
a lot of [ __ ] was going on and i just
did and in my mind i just didn't
put two and two together to be like yeah
shit's moving in
in that during that year for the tailors
for sure it's like yo this like you guys
are
like really you know it's crazy because
my grandma died
uh from covid she was in a nursing home
and we
and we couldn't see her like at all so
like for like
the first like two months of covert 19
my grandma is like super
old and so she had like light
light dementia so she didn't see any of
this for like
45 days before she died she saw nobody
from her family so
that [ __ ] was rough to swallow because
it was like damn like
she she might thought everybody was dead
or you know what i'm saying like they
wouldn't it was crazy
yeah because they're when you in that
like i said my granddad passed away from
dementia and the only thing
at the and this is the man that used to
take me to every sport event i had
but the only thing i would go over there
on wednesdays
the only thing he knew me by was apple
pie
because that's what i used to bring
that's what he liked i used to bring it
on wednesday
like he forgot my name damn he'd just be
like when he see me he'd be like apple
pie
and he know i'm about to give him you
know i'm saying the apple pie yeah which
was still cool
you know i'm saying i had to take it in
a cool way
yo that's wild man that's that's crazy
did you watch the democratic or the uh
the debate
did you see the debate i watched it with
the sound off
i was in the studio recording so i seen
it with the sound off
but i went to youtube last night when i
got to the crib and re-watched it wiz
was like
yo i was like yeah i'm gonna go watch
this [ __ ] when i get home he's like man
don't watch that [ __ ]
i'm like i got to see it i got to see
what they were saying yo what did you
think what did you think of it
um honestly
i mean lester are two evils
100 that's what i got from it
that's the joe biden bumper sticker
lesser of two evils vote for me for real
he needs to go about that because it's
basically
that you know i mean because you could
still like there's there's stuff from
back in the day that joe biden oh yeah
the 94 crime bill i mean look joe biden
is a very flawed candidate but for sure
he's not uh i think he does have
you know i think if you're the president
you got to like
have the quality to make people feel
like everything's going to be okay
even if it's not i feel like that is
like your job
you're supposed to go out and talk to
the whole entire country during times of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and make everyone feel like it's handled
when you see donald trump you look at
him and say we're [ __ ]
we're [ __ ] and do you see joe biden
and he's like
everybody just climb we're less [ __ ]
he might be old but at least he's got
the [ __ ]
at least he's got the young fly sister
with with her whack-ass timberlands you
know what i'm saying yeah she had the
one souls
yeah i'm like
[Laughter]
the new york people was getting on they
gotta stop trying to like make her
hip-hop
because she said that the [ __ ] tupac
was the greatest rapper alive
i'm like why is she even like like come
on leave it alone man
just leave it all and may the the other
way to look at that is maybe she knows
something we don't know
maybe tupac is alive man she ain't the
only one that know that [ __ ]
bro let me tell you that out loud for
like 10 years of my life i tried to
not probably like five years that he
left the country he's alive
bro there's so many things about tupac's
death that are wild like
if you listen to tupac's greatest hits
there's a song on there called uh
where he says he says rest in peace
biggie smalls in the beginning and
biggie died like
like [ __ ] nine months after tupac
died he said rest in peace [ __ ]
biggie smalls
and then at the beginning of machiavelli
he says suge shot me yeah he does i
heard that
bro there's a song on tupac's greatest
hits where he shouts out biggie being
dead
also there's uh he did
you know when they were putting out
those wack ass tupac albums where there
was like uh
just random ass like current rappers on
songs with tupac like why is
he shouted out trick daddy bro on one of
the songs and i'm like yo trick daddy
was not
a [ __ ] round bro in 96
yes he was yeah i mean but was he like
he would
i'm sure he was around but like was he
like this [ __ ] didn't know the
[ __ ] trick that he was what was the
first trip
bro like www.thug.com was like the first
album that had uh
i think that was like 99. like it was
99.90 no it was 99
no that was that was after that it was
popping it was the um
that was the nan that you know man okay
yeah
let's see one you might be right i think
that was like 98
99
trick's first album based on a true
story came out in 97. okay no but
the one that everyone knew him for doug
doug.com
but if his first hour what year 97 what
tupac died in 96 dog.com
okay if his first album came out in 97
he was probably already moving in 96.
tupac died in 96 and for the record but
you all know near [ __ ] didn't come out
in 96. 98 so 98 yeah listen man
nobody knew the [ __ ] trick daddy was
when chewbacca was alive god bless you
yeah i could i could now
not as you know you did the math yeah
so tupac i was thinking this
[ __ ] was alive
i'm like wait a minute why is he
shouting out biggie smalls
that [ __ ] [ __ ] i know he had a lot of
songs but like
he's got like [ __ ] 11 teen albums
since he's
[ __ ] died like how much [ __ ] that
would that's your
your your knowledge back then no you're
right now that i know that was that was
when i was a kid
but now i know that there's
[ __ ] who literally have like
five hundred songs on their hard drive
that nobody wants
to clip pieces he could say biggie
smalls he could say
rest in peace and they go clip true
they can make him say anything yeah
that's true as a kid you don't think
like with the [ __ ] process we didn't
exactly we didn't know about the [ __ ]
boards and working in the studios and
like all that [ __ ] back dude
just like tv bro hold on i'm about to
play this part bro i used to listen to
this song so much as a kid because i
heard him say that i heard this no you
heard the shook shot me everyone heard
that but nobody's never heard the biggie
smalls
people don't remember because people
ain't real tupac fans
and by the way i'm extremely critical of
tupac i think he's
one of the most overrated uh mc's ever
but i think as an artist he was
extremely important and incredible
um mc's m.c break it down i just feel
like lyrically
like lyrics like lyrically
flow-wise he was limited with his fl
like you think a biggie biggie could hop
on a song with bone
and do bone [ __ ] like i just feel like
tupac
as the whole package was one of the
greatest of all time it's one of the
most influential but i think when we
talk about like who's the
best rapper like pure rap skills i don't
think tupac's
i think he's around 11 or 12. not that
far
back well i guess if you because you're
gonna get you're gonna say
big daddy kane you're gonna say i'll put
royce the five nine over tupac as a
rapper
if we're talking about rapping
if we're talking about rapping i'm not
talking about making and by the way
royce is incredible but i'm saying
super though there's so many artists who
could wrap
circles around tupac
think of like this do you remember the
[ __ ] uh the biggie tupac freestyle
i got seven mac 11's about eight
nine all you gotta do is just listen to
that song and there's just like a very
big contrast on who was like the better
rapper
yeah in them three fifty seven [ __ ]
yeah he's small
the millionaire the mansion the yacht
the two hot glocks are two spots
so i got the weed spot i shot dread in
the head yeah put the bread in the lamb
spread
yeah all right hey shout out to the
tunnel from funk flex and big cap for
having that
back in the day yeah see word
play yeah i'll say word play
that's what i'm saying i'm not saying
that tupac was not [ __ ] broke two
parts one of my favorite i got you
underneath
one of my favorite rappers ever but you
know what people die on the tupac cross
like they die on like you know there's
two types of fans
that are very similar in two different
aspects of life
tupac rap fans and little wayne rap fans
i'll put those in the same
category because a little wayne fans are
[ __ ] crazy because they think he's
he's the second most overrated rapper
but nonetheless
um tupac fans i got rested soul kobe
fans
right if you talk to a kobe fan they
think kobe's like
one or two all time he's two you're
crazy
you're crazy these two to me
if you if someone asks you who's the
greatest nba player ever and you say
any other names besides michael jordan
or lebron james
you're just heavily biased and you grew
up like i mean will chamberlain did a
lot of [ __ ]
yeah but he was playing against
[ __ ] that look like me
i'll say that same i say this come on
story
but but there was just a bunch of
[ __ ] balding white dudes out there
bro
listen to this all right so this is
where i'm at with it we're
talking about we talked we talking about
rings right now this is what i'm gonna
say right
lebron this year is his tenth time going
to the league i'm going to
go into the championship right oh i
can't wait for i can't wait for this
argument you're about to make it if he's
horseshit
no if he if he wins
every time this man has
10 championship rings bill russell did
that yeah
and that against guys that look like me
in this era
lebron had the chance to do that are you
about to get in lebron's ass right now
pause
what i'm going to say is after he if he
plays these couple years and makes a run
of
three rings and gets past the five that
kobe has
on the stat board on the rings on
everything he's gonna be past
kobe so so can i point something out
because i think lebron
gets a really bad rap
for the how many times he's been to the
finals versus how many times he's won a
ring
like we don't talk about jordan or
kobe we don't talk about the year
kobe was on the lakers before they jerry
west handed them paul gasol for nothing
and they were a [ __ ] eight seed
getting bounced out
trust me the suns did it yeah but it's
the number but what i'm saying
is the years that kobe didn't make
the finals mm-hmm the years jordan
didn't they yeah
lebron's going to the finals like his
failure years are like
you know what he made it to the finals
but he's going to the finals and losing
hey would would
but what's okay a normal year for lebron
is making it to the finals right
a normal year for any uh jordan went to
the finals six times how many years did
he play 12 years 13 years yeah
so that means half of his career he
didn't go to the finals yeah
but when he went what did he do so is it
better if lebron had just gotten bounced
in the in the eastern conference finals
those years instead of going and losing
yeah no the level would have still been
the same they still would have been
saying he lost
so why don't they say that when kobe was
getting [ __ ] held skied up when he
had no help
because when he goes to the finals he
wins so
lebron how many times did kobe lose in
the finals he lost
celtics once but guess what guess what
the bronze other years lebron is year 17
he's made it to the finals 10
10 10 years so over half of his career
he's been in the finals right
he's probably going to go another at
least one time with the lakers
because charles barkley hates sitting up
on that charles barkley's a [ __ ]
and i don't know he's sitting up on that
panel with shaq bro because he don't
have no chips
that's fine but lebron's got chips yeah
but he broke lebron james he's losing
his one
ring he's about to win a ring with his
third team he loses in a chip
he okay so this is where
you have no argument here let's look at
who lebron's competition has been in the
finals all right the only one i'll give
you
there's only one ring that he lost that
was unexcusable and i was against the
mavs in
2011. that was a joke
that's his black eye on his career is
that one series
outside of that the nba is
crazier than ever jordan couldn't get
out of the east in the 80s
because of detroit the sixers the
celtics
right figured it out by the way by the
way
you watch the last dance and and they're
like
yo jordan was facing a feisty
cavaliers team and who were the best
players on the cavaliers mark price and
[ __ ]
or no yeah craig hilo mark price and
[ __ ]
brad daughtry and jordan had hard times
getting past them
nonetheless that was the year of the i
think the
white hoop dude was nice as hell all
right
listen listen listen lebron is no
like nobody's ever [ __ ] faced tougher
competition in the finals
that's a fact this man went against peak
spurs before kauai
right as a kid with nobody he had daniel
marshall
eric snow was his starting point guard
and they had big z
this was before mo williams was even on
the team they went to the finals
obviously he got smashed by the [ __ ]
spurs because we're talking peak spurs
right this is [ __ ] duncan
duncan genobley tony parker in in their
[ __ ] greatest
he had to play the mavs which they
should have won
no [ __ ] then they played the thunder
with
three future nba mvps on the roster
they had james harden kevin durant and
russell westbrook all on the same
[ __ ] team
lebron made light work of them year two
then the next two years
it's battles with the spurs this is new
peak spurs
with [ __ ] kawhi leonard and he splits
it 50 50. they get one they get a wing
running here
kawhi wasn't averaging 20. but he was
locking [ __ ] the [ __ ] down
he was bruce berwick no he wasn't come
on he won he won a
a finals mvp the you're the second one
yeah but i'm saying
yeah all right i'll give him so he
played played in it twice so
then he has to go against the [ __ ]
warriors bro
who's legitimately the greatest team
i've ever
i think ever if you were to just put
like talent you throw the warriors with
katie steph and clay on the [ __ ]
against anybody like
yeah so he has to play them four years
in a row
year one kyrie and kevin love are
injured
matthew dellavedova is his [ __ ]
started point guard he's got [ __ ]
uh mozgov got all this [ __ ] you gotta
give him to you now what do you mean to
hold him up
he took the [ __ ] he took he took the
cavaliers to six
or he took the warriors to six they they
should have won the series and they did
then the next year they win
greatest [ __ ] ring ever won down 3-1
lebron wins the greatest ring anyone's
ever won
and then and then the next two years
they just run into the buzzsaw of like
bro it's kevin durant
and the and the warriors it wasn't fair
they ruined the nba but i say all that
to say lebron has had the toughest
competition
and he's about to win his third ring
he's better than kobe
he's better than kobe of course you're
crazy
kobe's like top seven player of all time
he's certainly not top so eminem is top
three rappers top five for you
that's what it sounds like like it's
like like there's no way
it's like not look wait wait are you
comparing eminem to
look lebron is is jay-z
not eminem come on man lebron is jay-z
yes
and jordan is rock him bro
number two is he's not lebron is number
two bro
kobe sure looks like a number two yes he
is you're crazy
kobe is number two though can we pull up
what year seven can we fill up what year
number seventeen look like for kobe
versus what it looks like for lebron
actually let's look at my phone
kobe bryant is for sure different
well it's just not even close year 17
lebron did you see lebron james to score
38 points 16 rebounds and 10 assists in
an elimination game in the western
conference
i don't know if you saw that he's 35
years old so you're 17. i know this is a
different type of
animal and he's about he's a different
type of animal you i mean you put in
no you're right four to five million
dollars in your body at this point
closing them kobe wasn't not doing that
so we so toby did a lot of that since
you give no kobe head
you know one big thing is with kobe
gonna get that surgery overseas that's
what people know
people don't know that he was if he was
work it's it's
out there that lebron puts four five six
seven million dollars in his body
as far as training and doing all of that
[ __ ] you know why but it's like it's
like the greatest of all time but think
about it it's like the rappers not
having
twitter and instagram and youtube at the
time and then
one of the then lebron comes along and
he got twitter and youtube and instagram
and now
i don't think it's the same thing it is
shout out to lebron though yeah
he's he's yeah shout out to lebron he's
number three so um my favorite player is
carmelo by the way
really yes oh you're one of those guys
of all time
i mean i respect it that's the reason
that's an original scottie
you used to be scottie pippen carmelo
was a
fun to watch they should have did
something with the [ __ ] when they had
ai that would have been crazy
yeah i like that squad um
so you
are you vote are you voting uh do you
vote no
i haven't i mean i live out here now so
are you registered out here no
oh you see you gotta so i gotta fly back
home now you gotta do the absentee
ballot bro
uh pennsylvania is a [ __ ] uh it's a
really [ __ ]
that's a swing state man i found the
song by the way
tupac song why is it not playing it's
cause it's [ __ ]
are you telling somebody about it the
governor the government doesn't want us
to know tupac's alive bro
look at my new xbox hit the power button
and it don't work
why is it not playing on my spotify
god bless the dead is the name of the
song pull up on youtube
listen to this [ __ ]
see see that's how it's clipped i would
have been through that play it back
watch watch this i'm gonna tell you why
it's clipped
the word [ __ ] is missing recent piece
of my [ __ ] [ __ ] biggie smalls
they clipped it resting pizza my
[ __ ] biggie smalls don't nobody
talk like that bro
maybe tupac does the [ __ ] you don't know
that man and
somebody in cuba probably knows him
so if you were to vote you would vote
for uh or this year would you vote for
the biden man yeah like i said lester
are two evils
that would be the only reason yo what's
up man bullet kev here shout out to the
homies at odd socks
for sponsoring the bootleg cab podcast
and showing us love
man and let me tell you something we
don't take everyone's money
that's not true we'll take everyone's
money but donald trump's but with that
being said we [ __ ] with odd socks all
right
um i've been rocking odd socks for like
eight years now
and um man christmas time coming up make
sure you get you some odd socks
first of all let's talk about these
basics right here
these joints are the most comfortable
socks i've ever put on my feet all right
no design no license but just crazy so
make sure you get some of those
all right then they got the nickelodeon
they got the uh
scarface they got tapatio they got wwe
how about chef from southpark you know
what i'm saying whatever you need
shout out stone cold steve austin by the
way these are the socks that i wear when
i uh
drink pbr and yell at my wife uh
anyway um shout out to old dirty bastard
too
go to oddssoxofficial.com right now
all right right now go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the keyword
bootleg kev
and you will receive 20 off at checkout
go do that
uh all right so your album is out and um
it's been out for it's been out for a
while now yeah july 3rd
yeah um hey what's up with the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] methodical
taylor gang album that i've heard music
that was supposed to be on
for like the last eight years of my life
like what is going on is that ever gonna
i think everybody just started putting
out
like this [ __ ] like singly first just to
build that back up because you know we
did an
uh one before a volume one yeah but that
was more like a tape
yeah wasn't there supposed to be like an
actual album
yeah but that was like that was like the
tape yeah it was the tape but
we're we're we're working on the album
now but it's just like everybody start
doing their own
so who is like because i i know like
once people are taylor gang you know
it's usually
everything and you know everything's
kosher but like who's officially
taylor gang now like official like who's
on the label now
because you don't see like i don't see
juicy j banging taylor game like you
used to you know what i'm saying
i mean you know [ __ ] happens
so juicy j's not taylor gang anymore i
mean like you said once you taylor gang
you taylor gang man you know we
i'll be seeing you know people still be
wearing their chains
and stuff like that do you get the chain
back once they leave the crew it's like
hey yo
this is yours as far as as long as there
was only one circumstance that that
happened
you had to get the chain back i didn't
have to get it back who got whose chain
got taken back
i'm gonna get into all that i mean come
on man no that's cool
was it uh somebody like bigger
uh i didn't get him too long
i you know i mean for me once i once i
rep it i rip it and i'm here
did the chain have to get taken back
i'll take a guess i'll be like probably
like
14 maybe it was back wow
15. you know what i mean you know
sometimes business stuff don't work out
for
people and it doesn't necessarily have
to mean what's it uzi give
like give me the chain back type of deal
you know what i'm saying it's not like a
because i heard you don't give me that i
heard uzi was close to being taylor gang
yeah i mean dj drama and then was family
so yeah you know
so uzi got his chainsaw lake is family
you know what i'm saying
uh don cannon his family shout out to
don cannon yeah
all right well um yeah
yeah man and you know like i said once
it's taylor genghis always taylor gang
especially with me isn't it
still taylor gang no i'm gonna say
because that that was i feel like that
was the only exception of things i
thought that got kind of sketchy
publicly
where it felt like you guys like it was
like a weird split i feel like everybody
else is just kind of like
yeah i mean it's different when it's you
know
i guess it's different because we
haven't really like parted ways with
like no women
like rappers or you know i mean stuff
like that so i guess it was probably
kind of like a different thing
right right when you part ways like that
and they got to say what they got to say
anyway yeah
i feel like no matter what like ty is
going to always be
terry being affiliated burner will
always be taylor getting affiliated to
some capacity like
even if now when you speak of affiliated
that's more like it you know what i mean
it's it's people that's like you know
there's like a difference between being
signed to the label right and then just
being
yeah just being the homies of
you know what i'm saying for sure you're
still popping i still support you and do
all of that
but i just in my my years of dealing
with people i just know some things that
i just be like yeah i know what's up
with you still what's up though
you know what i'm saying but have you
ever been in any rap beefs
in your career no no beefs no
no no that's a positive no
some little stuff back home but it
wasn't like not like some actual like
like you know i never got into with
nobody the closest thing i probably got
into
with somebody was like um you remember
trail used to hang with tiger uh oh wait
not fatro
no no i don't oh yeah yeah like we just
had some words on the internet
and then we were we'd seen each other in
dubai and it was like this [ __ ] never
happened you know what i'm saying so it
was like
that's like the closest thing to
anything damn
that's the guy who had like one arm or
said something wrong with his
hand or some [ __ ] no that's dumb that's
the
you know where the tiger store is right
now where what well you used to head
attack
he used to head out yeah that's where he
got his spot now
i think it's like him and his his lady
shout out to uh
to tiger for having a comeback that i
didn't see [ __ ] coming
because lane he found it i feel like he
just did this is the thing with tyga
tiger like
had his lane and then he stopped running
in it
and then his [ __ ] hit a wall for like a
long time
and then he just made [ __ ] again that
like he should have never stopped like
well also too i believe i mean it was
public
that he had [ __ ] going on with cash
money
oh yeah but i know but he was putting
out a lot of [ __ ] through empire that
was just
atrocious music he was putting out some
really bad [ __ ]
and then you know he finally got back to
making like i think that's what happens
with artists though
this [ __ ] was trying to sing and
like he was just like bro like talk
about
strippers and [ __ ] [ __ ] and do it
over 100 bpms
like you know you know he's back shout
out to saga your album is out
go support it yeah um you have any
anything else like any other ventures
that you're
you want to shout out or you know you
know in quarantine i started the cooking
[ __ ] so
oh yeah you can cook now are you better
than brandon scales though that's what
we're trying to figure out we won't find
out but
i'm putting money on vdot i know he's a
beast
yeah i mean he's like a [ __ ]
five-star chef that guy
i am too i don't get no stars you know
what i'm saying but
yeah that man what got you into cooking
though i used to just hang around the
kitchen
with my grandma and my mom and she's so
have you always been a cook or is this
recently no
i mean i left my mom's house when i was
like 20.
so like being on my own kind of like
figured that [ __ ] out but i'm saying
like you like where you really started
to get passionate about cooking
like has that been always been a thing
or is that something that's just been
like
no it's just been in the kitchen for me
until
i really like start reading books and
[ __ ] like that and start
watching [ __ ] i've been watching
[ __ ] cook on youtube
all the time and as i said like for the
to make it good with chevy woods it's a
series it's
10 episodes damn all right and then
you've been working out too
yeah so you work out where whiz is at
which is the
was it called unbreakable unbreakable
which is shout out to jay glazer
jay glazer fox nfl insider yes sir
so what kind of people work out over
there um
oh [ __ ] football players basketball
players actors
who's been the most random actor that or
like like
coolest actor you've met over there or
like seeing over there um
that's a good question i mean maybe
maybe me and usher
sure yeah cause the cool thing about it
is
he like comes in and like does his work
and like
he says what's up to everybody of course
and stuff like that but he's like real
focused on what he's doing
and he rides his bike there and back to
wherever he's going
oh sure just riding a bike i met usher
at ty's house last year
and it was one of the coolest i don't
get you know i don't care i care about
nobody
right i was like man i'm literally in
ty's kitchen with usher
talking like just going in deep with him
about the game of thrones season
series finale i was like damn
if i was a kid and somebody told me i'd
be hanging out with usher
right that should be crazy yeah that
[ __ ] don't happen to me with a lot of
dudes you know but like
usher i was like this is [ __ ] crazy
real like yeah
like i was hanging out with busta rhymes
too like a couple weeks ago and that
[ __ ] was like
wow i'm really telling busta rhymes
how excited i was when him and mystical
got on a song together when i was a kid
like that's lit though like this is
crazy like
i got like that around buster when i
first met him i was just like [ __ ]
yeah and i've seen busta around but like
i actually was like you know we're in
very intimate space had a conversation
for about an hour and i was like this is
crazy if you were telling me as a kid
i'd be kicking him with busta rhymes
having like
real conversations with him i tell you
you're full [ __ ] or i'd be like yo i
made it in life
right it's crazy man i think it's like
that for me with snoop yeah
even with snoop you know doggy style was
the first uh
cassette tape i got me in the hip hop
like i got it on accident
and uh i was like seven six
and i learned that whole bro i had that
whole i know that like that's like my
favorite top three four favorite album
ever
you ever noticed like uh so
obviously with the storytelling from the
east coast it's like slick rick
yeah like infused like that's where
snoop
oh snoop was sup man that's why as a kid
we loved it so much because it was
storytelling yeah for sure
and you could follow it easy bro i when
i heard uh snoop's version of lottie
dottie like
i didn't even know there was a slick
rick version at the time i was like
[ __ ] in kindergarten mm-hmm
yeah when he did hit with yeah it's
crazy i was like and then i heard the
slick rick i'm like this [ __ ] is whack
yeah the snoop one is the one right but
but because it's the one i listen i
heard i got
like i knew that one mm-hmm yeah it's
crazy snoop is one of them ones man it
was like
i got to see snoop once and smoke with
him and you know
i'm cool with his boy kev shout out to
my guy kev but yeah like snoop snoops
are [ __ ] like yeah shout out to the
cab i'll be
he'd be working out of [ __ ] too with
snoop now i've seen that
yeah man i gotta get in the gym but i i
ain't going to unbreakable i can't
afford it
uh anyway yo wrapping up the podcast
chevy woods
go get his project it's out and uh
follow him twitter instagram and
cooking good with chevy woods make it
good make it good with chevy woods
the youtube series is that officially
launched yes
right yes it's uh you're on ten
yeah i'm on ten i shot 10 and now i'm
working on season two so we got to
[ __ ]
i just want to go on bro we're doing
something different the chef battle with
you and beat out skills needs to happen
i'll be a judge facts you and uh uh
nate my homie nate shout out to nate
yeah i feel like i always see nate in
random places in william hill's show
nate is the man with random places
he is he's the man he black bro did not
see
yeah he know what's up he being low-key
as hell
anytime i want to go somewhere like i
want to do something i'll be like what
should i do bro
yeah he'd be knowing all the spots here
wineries and all types yeah shout out to
nate man
anyway yo wrapping it up bootleg podcast
we out yo